we just watched the season nine finale
of when calls the heart
and oh my gosh lucas and elizabeth are
officially engaged elizabeth will you
marry me
yes
[Music]
erin can you take me back to that day on
set when you knew you were filming this
proposal scene what was the vibe what
was the energy i think that everyone
involved in a scene like this cast and
crew understands the importance of it
and so um
there was a lot of care put into even
just making sure that that
road looked romantic and autumnal and
you know they decorated it with some
beautiful leaves and they just wanted it
they wanted to imbue it with that magic
magical romantic feeling um so there was
a lot of care that went into it and then
like just so much time it took
a really long time and part of that was
just because we wanted to take our time
with it and make sure it was
as wonderful as it could be and part of
it was just the nature of working with a
toddler sometimes things take a bit
longer so yeah many distracting puddles
along the way
it'd be really difficult not to float
leaves as boats at every single puddle i
think that might have eaten up just a
little bit of time wait so was that you
chris or hyland no that was me oh right
right okay yeah chris loves a good
puddle he just can't resist
irresistible chris i want to ask you
because your character lucas
historically over the years the guy
knows how to put on the razzle dazzle he
knows how to deliver a grand gesture and
i really loved that this proposal
was seemingly decidedly intimate was
this something that you guys talked
about was it a creative decision that
you wanted to keep it just amongst the
three of them and and keep it i don't
know kind of low key i think that we
were all on the same page uh in that
regard and i also feel like we all
thought it would be great and all i mean
aaron and i and john i feel like uh we
wanted to include little jack in there
somewhere as well and
especially since
this season elizabeth has been
helping lucas grow as a birth person and
realize that not everything has to be
done
in a grand gesture so this was his
opportunity to
acknowledge that he's uh that's
resonated with him and he's taken the
biggest moment of his life so far and
made it into the most intimate um kind
of special personal and private way
possible i think john and our writers
did a really beautiful job creating a
proposal that felt unique to this couple
and this young family and quite frankly
different from
the jack and elizabeth proposal which
was you know over the top in in that way
i thought that the way it was handled
was really
understated and um spoke to the more
mature connection that these two people
have together and
i'm i was really happy with it
and chris just did such a beautiful job
i mean it was like i didn't have a ton
to say as he was going through his
speech and it was just like i didn't
have to um i don't have to work that
hard because you're just like looking at
his sweet face saying these beautiful
words and then he was like i think i
want to twirl you they want to just like
scoop you up and twirl you
[Music]
was that improvised was that something
that chris just kind of felt instinctual
to you because that's how it felt on
camera it felt like a like the moment
deserved to twirl
so yes
yeah you know you ever have those
moments in your life where you're like
um
this is a twirl moment
it was one of those
that's a twirl moment
there's another squirrel sir oh it's
okay i hope we get a puppy cameo at some
point during this interview nothing
he's a little distracted right now but
if he calms down i'll bring him right i
really loved in the writing of this
episode that before lucas
asks elizabeth to be his wife
he says allow me to be a father to your
son
was that intentionally put before the
marriage proposal because little jack
has really become such a beautiful focal
point of not just elizabeth's storyline
but now also lucas's i think john
definitely put that first on purpose
yeah i think that it's a a priority that
little jack is taking care of and has a
father figure and of course both
being a husband and a father are
important things but i i feel that
john wanted to lay down that
lucas is very very serious about being a
role model and a father figure to jack
so that's why it was prioritized i don't
think i gave
too much thought to the the order of of
what he was saying but i mean i suppose
if it had been the reverse
and lucas had said will you be my wife
oh by the way i also want to be a father
to your child but it doesn't really like
flow quite as well so
i think that makes sense
i agree with the way it was handled yeah
it was so beautiful and i really loved
the natural way that little jack was
integrated into the scenes he's
collecting rocks before he gives his mom
the rock
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
how did highland enjoy being a part of
this scene oh
poor highland actually i think he had a
cold that day and some of the um
the audio from that scene you can just
hear his little like rattly breathing as
he's running along to scoop up rocks but
um he was still in good spirits and he
was you know like chris said he was just
pretty distracted by the nature around
him he's a little boy and he was having
a good time highland's uh you know he's
a really great kid and and he's
despite the puddles he's typically quite
focused and he just seems to
authentically enjoy being there
and uh and being a part of those scenes
with us so i mean it really wasn't
it wasn't that
that difficult that scene went by pretty
smoothly do you think he understands
what a proposal is like was he asking
you questions about the scene or did you
guys explain anything to him along the
way i know his parents uh
go through the script with him and kind
of explain what's happening in the
scenes and they work with him a lot
they're great and i know that he has
been watching the show and
covers his eyes when there's any kissing
so
um so he understands the like kissing
romance elements of it but i'm not sure
if he understood that this proposal
meant okay the three of us are becoming
a family now and chris i have to tell
you it melts my heart every single time
i hear
little jack call lucas buddy
we sure did
how did that come about was that
scripted or was that is that like a term
of affection that you and hyland use
together it's scripted but i think
it i might be wrong with this um but i
i'm fairly certain it came from peter de
luis it came from his past and a
relationship he had with his grand
grandparent or father something and the
word buddy was used as a term of
endearment and that's how it made its
way into the script i think that is true
but i also thought that it was initiated
by you
calling highland buddy just like off the
cuff one day and then they wrote it in
because it was meaningful to peter and
because it made sense for your
characters erin when you and i spoke at
the beginning of season nine you held up
your hand to the camera and you said
this is the same ring that i've been
wearing since season one i took it off
temporarily when i was wearing the
engagement ring and wedding band um
from jack rest his character's soul and
it's back so uh maybe something will
replace it on my left hand this season
fast forward here we are
season nine finale she's got a new
beautiful shiny ring did you have a say
in picking out this exact ring yeah and
not just me i mean chris and i had some
conversations about it it had to make
sense as a piece of jewelry that lucas
would select for elizabeth so i think i
think we all did a nice job creating
that together you did chris what were
your opinions about picking out a ring
for your your on-screen fiance nobody
liked my picks i i you know i was going
for like like half an inch by half an
inch like just a you know a big rock
like i don't know chris but they were
being so kind about that sure i'm just
kidding none of that happened we were
all on the same page we all wanted
something that was elegant and classy
and kind of timeless something that
represented things that lucas i guess
hold dear i'm keeping my fingers crossed
for a season 10. i'm just gonna talk
like we have a season 10 because i
really like to live in a world where
we're not going to get to see what's
next with this and elizabeth as they go
into this really exciting
life erin do you see lucas and elizabeth
having a big grandiose wedding with all
their friends and family there or kind
of true to the proposal do you maybe see
them doing their own thing and maybe
eloping doing something small and
intimate as a as a family oh maybe we
could have a travel episode where lucas
and elizabeth go to paris or something
that would be fun can we shoot it in
paris too yes we have to shoot in paris
well they'll send us to like vegas or
something yeah you could see it going
either way
i don't know if it would be in jack's
church maybe somewhere else
okay chris have you thought about this
at all like do you have a vision for for
how your character might type
you're like nope
i just take things one time one thing at
a time so if we get a 10 then
i'll consider it i don't want to jump
the gun too much but aaron again i gotta
thank you for a brilliant moment you
gave me um in the beginning of season
nine when i speculated that you know
possibly we could uh
we could maybe see some more kids in
elizabeth's future and you said it
probably gets the ovaries going i would
think
can i say that oh man why did i say that
because it's ironic because the fans
loved it and we hold on to that moment
so dearly
so now fast forward here we are do you
think there are children in in elizabeth
and lucas's future but i think
that
elizabeth and lucas are on the right
track for a really beautiful love story
and they have
little jack to focus on and whether
their family is complete the three of
them or
you know if it grows there's just an
awful lot of love there between them and
um
yeah i'm excited to
see where it could go chris you want
more kids on set you want to see uh your
character your character expand the
family a bit
i'll take more highlands on set
highland's a blast oh he's great
i want to ask you guys a question about
nathan my goodness we are in such a
different place than we were
a year ago when the the feelings were
sad and emotional and here we are we've
got nathan teasing elizabeth in such a
sweet and loving way we've got nathan
spending one-on-one time electively with
lucas and i loved that uh that he said
in the season nine finale you could do a
lot worse than marrying bouchard
try not to lose him like you'll ask me
so erin how do you feel about these
characters being in such a healthy place
i'm really happy with where things ended
in the dynamic at the end of season nine
i think that there's still a lot of care
between those characters all three of
them for each other and that's just
displayed in different ways you're right
and the you know poking fun
nathan does a lot of poking fun of both
elizabeth and lucas
but
um i guess elizabeth anyway kind of put
him through it so maybe she deserves it
i just really appreciate it i think it's
a very natural
but still very caring dynamic
and chris did you ever think that your
character and kevin's character would
get to this place where they're i don't
know they seem like they were friends
hanging out when they were out together
in the woods yeah i hoped
that they would get there
and it's happened so if we uh we do a
season 10 i'm looking forward to seeing
how it progresses from there and i don't
know if this has anything to do with
part of the reason why i think these
characters have been able to move on so
maturely but it seems like nathan has
found happiness with miss may sue is it
fair to think that that may sue and
nathan are together i think things were
perhaps intentionally left
a little ambiguous right hopefully we'll
be able to explore that more in the
season 10. i hope but you know there was
exploration with may
there was what appeared to be flirtation
with faith i sort of hope for everyone's
sake that we're not
on our way toward another triangle
because
i'm not sure i can take it but
um
but it seems like
nathan
is opening his heart again and
i imagine he will i mean he's a real
catch so i'm sure he will find love very
soon
[Music]
you